[Music]
all right welcome back israeli and
palestinian protesters gathering in new
york last night after the announcement
that ceasefire in the middle east
bringing an end to the 11 days of war
we've seen there causing all that
destruction
inside israel and in the gaza strip
all right you can see some of the
violence that ensued in new york last
night protests turning violent that
brought between pro-israeli and
pro-palestinian protesters and then
this happened there was an incident
yesterday multiple people arrested it
here and you can see
despite the ceasefire announcement
between israel and hamas the tension
between the groups continues to escalate
pro-palestinian protesters are even
accused of throwing fireworks
professional-grade fireworks into a
crowd in manhattan's diamond district
and if you know anything about new york
you know they're obviously seeking out
the jews
that work in the diamond district now if
the fireworks during this protest
remind you of anything you might be
reminded of
the commercial grade fireworks we saw
used by antifa
during their protests in portland last
year we're not saying there's a
connection here at least
other than those fireworks but let's
talk about this more and what's going on
with these anti-semitic attacks
and welcome in the host of the reuben
report dave rubin author of don't burn
this book
thinking for yourself in an age of
unreason
you know dave anyone who knows anything
about new york city knows the diamond
district
is where a lot of hasidic jews go to
work
they are wear their traditional clothing
they're
obviously identifiable and we're seeing
this in new york we're seeing this in
los angeles
people who are visibly jewish are being
attacked
uh by these quote-unquote
pro-palestinian protesters but there's
got to be more to it than that
uh well i don't think there's much more
to it than that
this is what the left has wrought on
america they have played a deeply
dangerous game
of identity politics and jews don't fit
the intersectional calculator
jews are a minority with a brutal
history that by boat
most estimations probably shouldn't
exist anymore but somehow
through hard work and education and
family and freedom and liberty and all
of the things
has afforded us have become a successful
minority
that is against the marxist world view
that is against now the modern
democratic party
world view that is against everything
that aoc and hamas spokesman ilhan omar
and uh bernie sanders now stand for
so the fact that these people are
specifically targeting
jews they're not just targeting israelis
not that that would be any better as
you're making a clear point they are
going to
i lived in new york city most of my life
if you wanted to see some jews
you'd go to the diamond district it's
you know basically two blocks right
there you know exactly where to go
there to hunt down jews simple as that
and you know silence from mainstream
media you're gonna get
virtually nothing out of cnn i finally
saw yesterday jake tapper
managed to he tweets every two minutes
he finally managed to tweet out
one thing i mean this is what the left
has brought
a bunch of us have been warning about it
and here it is you know it's interesting
jake tapper's so quick on the trigger to
call out our colleague grant stinchfield
uh for his comments
last week but when they're you know
throwing commercial grade fireworks
into you know pro-israel demonstrators
it's hard for him to even say anything
you know the other thing too dave you
know you're in la and this one
used to be one of the areas where you
know you'd have the jewish community in
hollywood
stand up with the way i think a lot of
americans feel in solidarity with israel
and i love the fact that you posted this
old clip of joan rivers
uh may she rest in peace from back in
2014 here
here she was asked about this same thing
that happened basically
uh seven years ago um and here's what
she said about this
i'm trying to get celebrity reactions to
what's going on with the palestinian
israelis right now
let me just tell you if new jersey were
firing rockets
into new york we would wipe them out
i am so bored we heard they were digging
tunnels
from new jersey to new york we would get
rid of jersey
so i don't want to hear anymore oh we'll
do a partial cruise
and palestinians you cannot throw
rockets and expect people not to defend
themselves
you know and and the the reporter from
tmz said well how do you know this
joan you're you're you know you're a
comedian you're an actress and she's
because i've been there
you know and i love the geographic
reference there because that's what
we're talking about these aren't
countries that are far apart you know
this is gaza literally
launching these rockets indiscriminately
down into israel
and joan rivers of course had the spine
to stand up
but today sarah silverman you know she
says
jews in the dysphoria need allies we are
not from israel
you know that's modern hollywood
compared to old hollywood dave yeah i
mean
sarah silverman is just a disgusting
vile creature who's trying to buy
herself
an extra socially distanced party in
hollywood before they come for her let's
not forget she's been in blackface
and made fun of gay people and blah blah
blah on her twitter bio it says
that she's from palestine i mean she's
just an absolute self-hating joke
i have nothing else to say about her in
case my feelings aren't clear but we
need
joan rivers and we need people that will
stand
up and tell the truth we are talking
about
an area of land the size of new jersey
an obscenely tiny
area of land that there is one obscenely
tiny jewish state there's an awful lot
of christian majority states an awful
lot of muslim majority states
there are many arab states in the area
as you know
no country known as palestine ever
existed if the egyptians
if they cared about their brothers in
gaza they could open up the border but
no they bombed the border
this is simply about whether jews can
exist or not that's it
that's what this is about and by the way
i think i can speak for all jews
when i say we don't want any special
treatment we want to be treated as
crappy as everybody else just not worse
well you know that's what equality is
all about that's the promise of america
right we can all treat each other like
crap
but let's do it equally right no it's
it's it's well put dave because that's
what we do
today we treat each other like crap uh
but one
group of of our population shouldn't be
treated worse than everyone else because
it's something they have no control over
absolutely zero
control over and that's really what this
boils down by the way john john even if
you disagreed with every single one of
his israel's policies which i don't i'm
not saying they're all right
but even if you disagree with every
single policy we cannot have
violent religious sectarian violence in
the united states of america
and that is what aoc and and ilhan omar
and rashidathi that is
actually what they want because that is
the end of identity politics
when you will walk around and you will
say oh black person must think this
jew must think this muslim must think
this gay person must think this
and we'll all hate each other and that
will thus turn america into the
very country that all of our
grandparents fled that's what they're
trying to do
and if if if i don't like what race you
are i don't have to do interviews with
you as someone oh yeah chicago
yeah lightfoot she's a real gem that one
racist
uh well we talked about her yesterday i
want to talk about chris cuomo now and
the cuomo brothers
uh and the advisory firm that is uh
chris cuomo the media advisor to his
brother andrew cuomo
uh let's play the clip in the mia culpa
here
how i helped my brother also matters
when my brother's situation became
turbulent being looped into calls with
other friends of his and advisors
that did include some of his staff i
understand why
that was a problem for cnn it was a
mistake
because i put my colleagues here who i
believe are the best
in the business in a bad spot i never
intended
for that i would never intend for that
and i am sorry
for that he never intended for that
because he probably doesn't think about
anything other than himself
and what's so ridiculous about this dave
is that
we expect it to stop they are brothers
they're going to talk uh when you talk
to your brother or i talk to my sister
you talk about some of the most intimate
things in your life
this isn't going to stop this is going
to continue
and how dumb are these or is his
audience for continuing to accept these
apologies from him oh i
i didn't mean to go outside without a
mascot you know whatever
john did you just ask me how dumb cnn's
audience is because i know we have a
limited amount of time here and i could
probably
refer to the numbers um look chris cuomo
is a character actor larping as a
journalist you know larping the phrase
larping live action role playing that's
what the kids do in college when they
pretend that they're you know medieval
nights and stuff
um he's not a journalist this is a man
who in the midst of pretending he was
quarantining because he had kovid
in his basement and they did a very
theatric moment when he moved came out
of his basement as if he hadn't seen his
family in weeks
it turned out a few days later it was
exposed that he literally got into a
fight with a bicyclist
in the hamptons in the middle of all
that this guy is a ridiculous buffoon
he should be fired not because of cancel
culture but because of basic
journalistic standards
he was a propagandist for his brother
who also is a murderer by the way i mean
we know that his brother sent all those
people
back into the old age homes i always say
i always advocate for due process we'll
say
people have accused him of murdering
folks dave we can't really call him a
murderer he's never been charged with
that but yeah john i'm a little fired up
i got you i got it i'll go with due
process all right fair enough john
uh you're you're a fine host by the way
um
yes his brother we know what they did
they were working together in tandem for
pr when it when it was working for them
and then the second it was exposed now
they have to sort of turn on each other
but he he's not a
journalist right he's not a journalist
no one at cnn is a journalist
these are propagandists simple as that
we'll put dave all right i want to do
something here pull back the curtain a
little bit
on our editorial process there's so many
stories every week i always look forward
to talking to you
but we're gonna do something here we
call stories we're not covering a lot of
media covered these stories this week
and we're gonna explain why we don't
have time to cover i would have loved to
cover the prince harry story
especially where he talked about the
first amendment being bonkers i mean
this guy
is the only thing more emasculating than
those army
uh recruitment ads here but you know we
don't have to talk about prince harry
because we fought a whole war
to not have to talk about that god we
don't have to talk about him we don't
have to care what he thinks
about the first amendment and i don't
care about his sit-downs with oprah
or his bad marriage or the fact that he
has now let
the woke virus enter into the monarchy
and it'll probably take down the
monarchy too because as we've talked
about many times this thing
this thing is an evil alien-like
parasite and once it's in it destroys
the institutions
so congratulations to the queen yes uh
we couldn't
destroy the british empire with our
revolutionary forces but prince harry
might do it with his wokeness the other
story we don't have time to cover here
even though it's really juicy
with all the back and forth is joy behar
and megan mccain
these ladies don't seem to like each
other very much and here's an example
if it's not the republican party so i
call it the q anon party
what should i call your party now who
defends people
like matt gates and goes against liz
cheney what are we supposed to call it
i think you can call it whatever you
explain your influence in the republican
party is almost zero
you know dave i never understand i mean
this a lot of people watch the view
why do people like to watch people tear
each other's heads off so much
especially joy behar she's just so mean
spirited
joy behar is the end of the road of
sarah silverman like sarah silverman i'm
sure you're a big news max viewer
it's like that is what you are going to
become joy was
once years ago believe it or not a
decent liberal i used to live a couple
blocks away from her in new york city
and we'd chat every now and again
and she was i would say a moderate
democrat but like
all of them she has really completely
lost her mind
and now fights for the very things that
she used to fight against and and vice
versa
meghan mccain is fantastic you know i
don't agree with all of her positions i
know her a little bit personally
but she is she is fighting i mean
imagine what a hostile situation i know
around that audience and those women all
day long saying awful things about you
just so that you can be all she is is a
moderate conservative it's not even as
if the trump people love her so much you
know
no no there's no the trump people
definitely don't love megan mccain
there's no love lost between the two but
yeah you make a great point and she does
megan mccain does you know strike a
chord a lot of times last story we're
not going to cover
dave is this you know very like this
very disturbing trend
in the nba of flopping going on somehow
european soccer has infected the nba
when we were growing up dave it was a
rough and tumble league you got
you know charles oakley and patrick
ewing going against you know michael
jordan and now lebron flops at the
slightest
little you know hint of contact what's
going i mean
we don't have to cover it we don't have
to cover it davey because apparently
nobody watches the nba anymore
well nobody watches the nba anymore this
is the most nba i've
watched uh in about three years so thank
you for that john but i would say lebron
who's the worst of the worst uh you know
his flopping is just a metaphor for all
his political beliefs yes they
they don't stand up to anything he says
something
and then he flops the second he realizes
what he said is nonsense still waiting
on you to comment on china
lebron but i know you want that contract
i know that's tough sure
you know million juggers being uh
genocided but you know
america is racist right lebron yeah yes
oh i hope he's okay
i mean i don't think the nba sucks look
at that it really does
it's so it's so bad boy pistons come on
yes
the good old days you know bird larry
bird used to
oh those were the good old days anyway
dave great to see you
good to see you john if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell